the storms were unlike anything anyone
had ever seen but the worst part wasn't
just the deadly gales wind howling
powerful enough to knock down buildings
like rows of dominoes and lift the
remaining debris of cities up into the
air as if all that destruction weighed
nothing and it wasn't just the lightning
those arcs of crimson forking down from
above if one struck the ground near you
and one almost always did the sheer
force of it would knock you off your
feet the last thing you'd feel as you
flailed helplessly in the air was the
relentless pain of your body being
disintegrated by the energy of the blood
red lightning until there was nothing
left of you for anyone to find yet
somehow that wasn't the worst part
either and it wasn't even the noise of
it all either that deafening cacophony
of booming thunder and wild hurricane
force winds so loud nobody could ignore
it all underscored by the screams of a
world lost in suffering and madness no
the worst part of it all was the sky
whether anyone looked up where there had
once been that clear calming blue was
now a swirling mass of nightmares many
were surprised just how much they missed
turning to that sky that odd universal
comfort it brought the knowledge that no
matter how bleak things got the sun
would set on every bad day and rise
again to mark the start of another
filled with potential that promise of a
future no matter how uncertain was
replaced with a reminder of one thing
that this new darker day had no end
there was no sunrise or sunset no night
or day all that uncertainty and
potential was replaced with certain doom
represented by a sky that looked like a
river of blood deep reds and blacks
swirled and thrashed above like the
raging waves of the ocean casting bolts
of lightning down at the earth not to
mention what else would occasionally
drop from that blood-stained sky nobody
had much information about how this all
had started how the world had become
such an unrecognizable hellscape cynics
would say that the world was already
hell long before the sky turned red
although there wasn't much time for
sarcastic jokes like that nowadays as
far as the few human beings that had
survived could remember the day
everything changed had been little more
than an ordinary day on planet earth one
moment things were normal people were
working tirelessly at their boring
nine-to-five jobs somewhere in the world
others had long since fallen asleep in a
different time zone then all of a sudden
it appeared few survivors had actually
seen it for themselves and even fewer
had lived to tell the tale but rumors
and whispers spread from camp to camp
dispossessed people huddling together in
the ruins of houses or in abandoned
subway tunnels that would hear the
stories and somehow deep down in the
fearful recesses of their hearts they
all knew despite never having seen it
that it was real the mast god when it
stepped upon the earth it walked like
any other person would its body even
appeared to be human an aged older man's
body wrinkled and elderly although not
completely decrepit yet it was his face
or what covered it that really instilled
that sense of fear and dread in anyone
that heard the rumors that being wore a
mask a porcelain comedy mask the kind
commonly associated with ancient greek
theater it had a fixed unnerving
expression a wide smile of twisted glee
it was almost as if it was getting some
sick enjoyment out of all the chaos and
destruction that had befallen the world
like it was pleased with its own
handiwork a thick black substance oozed
from the mask too adding to its
unsettling appearance as streaks of what
looked like tar trickled down the chalky
white surface it leaked out from
underneath as well dripping over the
bony shoulders of the old man that wore
it not one survivor that heard the
stories of this monster understood what
it was or where it had come from but as
if by some defyic influence they all
knew it was responsible for creating the
hell they now lived in that knowledge
kept them hidden kept them afraid and
kept them from fighting back as had
always been the case even before this
apocalypse had been unleashed on the
world the only people who knew the truth
were the ones who had been working for
the scp foundation they had more than
their fair share of answers about what
had happened and who or what this
mask-wearing menace was but naturally
kept that information secret from the
wider world not that there was much
point in keeping secrets anymore after
all there was hardly much of a world
left for the foundation to hide things
from and even fewer former personnel who
had lasted this long even then there was
only a handful at the scp foundation who
knew everything that had led to the
current catastrophe most of the
researchers and guards that had been
going about their ordinary duties
running tests on contained anomalies or
patrolling the site where a certain
possessive mask was housed the next
thing everyone there knew was the
blaring noise of alarms mobile task
force troopers racing down the hallways
their commander might have yelled
something about a break-in someone
having gained access to the supposedly
secure foundation facility and stealing
one of their anomalous objects but not
everybody even those working in the same
building would have overheard that they
definitely didn't miss what happened
next though as further alarms sounded
alerting the staff on site of a
containment breach the facility itself
was torn apart in a flurry of chaos
personnel researchers security mtf
soldiers were being incinerated burned
until there was literally no trace of
them left something stepped through the
very brickwork of the building itself
smashing a hole through every room it
passed until it burst out of the side
then all of a sudden the alarms weren't
the loudest sound something else started
deafening the foundation staff who were
still standing the world outside had
become even more chaotic the sky had
turned red and all around people were
being killed structures decimated cities
blown away in moments naturally this
wasn't the first time the foundation had
stared right into the face of an xk
class end of the world scenario given
the widespread presence and surveillance
they had around the planet it didn't
take them long to learn of the horrors
that were unfolding the key word there
was that they had a widespread presence
as in
past tense they thought they had enough
resources to retaliate too word quickly
spread throughout the various arms of
the scp foundation informing the wider
organization of the situation and urging
them to work as one to enact a plan to
stop what was happening all they knew
for certain was that
scp-035 had been removed from
containment also known as the possessive
mask the object was known to have its
own sentience and an innate ability to
telepathically influence unwitting
victims into wearing it however the mask
also secreted a corrosive black
substance which normally dissolved the
body of anyone who put it on by itself
scp-035 was nowhere near powerful enough
to unleash a global catastrophe though
unfortunately it had managed to
influence someone who was that powerful
into putting it on another anomaly well
to the untrained eye
scp-343 could easily be mistaken for an
elderly human man those at the
foundation knew that the fact he was now
wearing the possessive mask was some of
the worst news they could have ever
received although none of the
researchers working for the scp
foundation in fact not even the o5
council knew if this was true the
colloquial nickname for scp-340 was
god he not only claimed to be the sole
creator of the entire universe but had
also exhibited extensive reality warping
abilities advanced even for an anomalous
being his powers seemingly had no known
limit in how they could be used to alter
the world around him although the old
man himself seemed to be a passive
kindly soul rarely causing active harm
to other beings under normal
circumstances of course normal
circumstances didn't include having the
corruptive scp-035
on his face effectively putting the mask
in the driver's seat and allowing it to
use as cp-343's powers to lay waste to
anything before it the foundation
quickly diverted their considerable
assets to a brute force retaliation in
the hopes that a full-scale assault on
the combined creature would somehow
force a separation of the possessive
mask from
scp-343's face the tricky thing about
this situation was god's powers and the
fact that he was an immortal ageless
being of potentially incomprehensible
form all meant he couldn't be harmed
causing external damage to him was
extremely difficult that was good news
in some regard after all the foundation
didn't want to kill 343 if they could
help it they knew he wasn't acting on
his own accord but his indestructibility
also meant that the corrosive goo that
was secreted from
scp-035 had little to no effect on its
new impervious host that meant it could
keep going keep unleashing hell and
stopping it was going to take a lot of
manpower fortunately the scp foundation
never had any shortage of people to
throw at a problem and their ethos
didn't really place much value on human
life they mobilized every mobile task
force at their disposal every one of
them filled with ranks of highly trained
elite operatives among the foundation's
forces were even mtf agents who had
themselves been altered through
anomalous means their bodies augmented
with technology and cybernetics or their
strength specially enhanced deploying
the full might of their amassed forces
the scp foundation took the fight to
scp-035
with the goal of stopping its reign of
terror and freeing scp-343
if possible the hybridized mask-wearing
reality warper had already caused
considerable damage since it had started
its rampage although its motivations
were far from political the wearer of
the anguish mask had begun with a
devastating show of power wiping
numerous cities off the map while the
rest of the world scrambled to find some
way of responding the mast god
teleported itself across the globe
destroying central governments and
further crippling their own
opportunities to initiate an armed
response in short this meant the
foundation's move was to be humanity's
last stand their final chance to stop
scp-035 from its current course of
harnessing the wise old man's power to
turn the world into its own personal
nightmarish playground to say there was
a lot riding on the mtf assault would be
an understatement as would saying it
went badly when met with times of defeat
the old rather morbid adage of fallen
soldiers being sent home in bags is
often applied but if the masked hybrid
had sent the foundation its mtf troops
back to them encased in body bags then
that would have been far kinder than
what it actually did the collected
mobile task forces the foundation's own
private army were mobilized to
washington under the influence of the
possessive mask
scp-343 had wiped out not only the main
seat of power in the united states but
the pentagon as well disabling the
country's defenses suddenly a mass of
aerial transports and ground vehicles
came hurtling towards the crater it had
left behind as it turned to look the
wide grin of satisfaction on scp-035
became a long frown thanks to its new
hosts omniscience it instantly
recognized the foot soldiers of the
organization that had kept it caged for
so long as the amassed mtfs marched
towards it the masked gods stepped out
to meet the oncoming army one being
against thousands of troops if not tens
of thousands if the mask had affixed
itself to the face of any other anomaly
those soldiers might have stood a slim
chance the combined creature casually
raised the bony arms of its host body
the foundation forces breaking into a
charge the very second they saw it move
like a tidal wave they rushed towards
their target only for each individual
operative to quickly realize that they
had stopped moving they were still
running legs still in motion but their
feet had been lifted off the ground
plucked from the very earth they each
had stood on the mtfs were stuck in
mid-air defying the forces of gravity
and unable to free themselves
collectively the foundation's army
looked to scp-035
its tragic porcelain frown having
switched back to the wide grin
punctuating the sixth satisfaction it
was about to take from what came next it
gave a click of god's lean fingers and
each of the mtf troops it had suspended
in midair were shredded at the molecular
level their bodies erupted with a spray
of deep red viscera each and every one
of them being pulled to pieces from the
inside out flesh bone and blood melting
away breaking down becoming ash and then
atoms
and then
nothing it took around a minute not that
it was terribly exerting for scp-343's
powers but just because of how many
troops the foundation had sent to try
and stop it a mighty show of force and
all for nothing with their mobile task
forces decimated like a row of helpless
tin soldiers the scp foundation had lost
its primary method of fighting back but
they were far from safe from the mast
god's reach thanks to its hosts
scp-035 wasn't all-knowing but
all-seeing and able to be anywhere and
everywhere in the blink of an eye it
began hunting the surviving pockets of
the foundation personnel out of nowhere
it would teleport into wherever they
were hiding and turn their bodies inside
out or rearranging the functions of
every orifice on their faces only to
vanish like a ghost leaving no trace and
no survivors the braver ones tried
desperately to come up with some new
plan a revised way to stop a creature
that could be anywhere and do anything
on the other hand the foundation
leadership the more highly ranked
members like the overwatch council went
to the ground plenty of them had
contingency plans in place for
armageddon and they were prepared to
wait out the apocalypse in their own
secluded safe haven but with the
foundation all but gone that's when the
monsters got loose no longer having
anyone to guard them to maintain their
specific specialized containment
procedures the scps still held at
foundation sites were unleashed on the
world untold horrors came spilling out
of the ruined facilities each one now
acting as its own pandora's box bursting
its lock and having its terrible
contents lay waste to the planet already
awash with chaos a lot of the anomalies
thrived in the world that scp-035 had
created once they were finished fighting
amongst themselves in the struggle of
escaping their containment soon there
were packs of scp-745 running wild on
the ruined highways using their
bioluminescent lights to hunt human
survivors who were attempting to make
the dangerous trek across open country
meanwhile a plague began spreading
amongst other camps of these
post-apocalyptic humans a strange
disease that seemed to cause people to
rapidly grow extra teeth over producing
them until
scp-4910 the grinner could catch up to
them then there were the scps that fled
the nightmare that the masked god had
made of the world any that could travel
between dimensions or remove themselves
from this layer of reality quickly
absconded to avoid the chaos some just
went about their business as if nothing
had really changed the plague doctor
mostly kept to himself traveling from
place to place on foot only stopping
when he encountered people afflicted
with the pestilence before moving on in
search of others some of the anomalies
tried to help people rumors spread among
some survivor camps of a half-man half
cactus leaving them food and supplies in
the night with a note that read from
your friendly neighborhood cactus man
there weren't many who dared to oppose
the creator of this dark new world but
some anomalies sought to challenge the
rule of this combined creature perhaps
they thought
scp-035 and scp-343 couldn't possibly be
all-powerful as the story said that it
would be easy to kill the king and
assume control over his kingdom of chaos
there were plenty of other anomalies
that had floated the idea not just the
other reality warpers but those that had
figured out that if they separated the
mask from its host then this world would
become their hellish paradise to rule
over so long as scp-343 didn't instantly
undo all the damage but there was one
that didn't want control it didn't even
necessarily mind the whole world had
been turned into a walking nightmare it
just wanted to stand against the hybrid
of malicious mask and all-powerful deity
out of spite based on nothing but pure
hatred for any and all other forms of
life other than itself and it was that
confrontation that would serve as a
warning to the rest of the scps now
freely roaming the world
scp-682 slithered out into the open
claws coated with a fresh coating of
blood from its latest slaughter wetting
the countless layers beneath that had
already dried the hard to destroy
reptile had tracked the scent of the
possessive mask's oozing black
secretions bringing the beast maw to
porcelain face with the combined being
responsible for distorting the very
fabric of the world already knowing the
foul lizard was near thanks to its
host's foresight
scp-035's visage had already been locked
in that unhappy grimace dreading the
approach of the day it would have to
face the tenacious irritating
regenerative reptile it turned its
host's body to face the huge beast the
trails of black streak down its frowning
face looking like angry tears staining
its carved off-white skin the two
exchanged no words
scp-682 had no doubt this pairing of
corruptive mask and passive god already
knew why it had come looking for it and
it was right the possessive mask had
long been looking into the mind of
scp-343 to prepare it knew it wasn't one
of the old man's children in fact god
had completely denied ever being
responsible for the creation of the
unkillable monster there was almost no
strategy even with the infinite power of
its hosts reality warping abilities that
scp-035 could definitively kill
scp-682 building up to a charge the
reptile swiped at the mast god its
talons narrowly nicking the porcelain
surface of the mask the very second it
teleported out of the way reappearing
behind the monster
scp-035 compelled its host body to lift
its elderly arm and decimate the beast
the same way it had to the foundation's
forces with a fearsome hiss the
reptile's body was pulled apart it
growled with anger annoyed and enraged
more than deterred its strong scaly
limbs quickly regenerated bone and
muscle regrowing to replace what the
mass god had torn away
scp-682 gave a swipe of its tail
knocking the mast god a few feet away
reeling him the anomalous hybrid
teleported yet again this time to inside
the monstrous reptile shrinking down to
almost infinitely small the mask and god
wrenched apart
scp-682's atoms ripping up strand after
strand of its very dna physically trying
to unmake it on a cellular level on the
outside the creature's body
disintegrated as it roared feeling its
very genetic material breaking down only
for it to rapidly reform just as scp-343
wearing
scp-035 reappeared in front of it there
was no way for the mast god to kill the
monster despite how much it tried
sending it hurtling into the fire of the
sun punching it into other dimensions
moving it down the recursive stack of
reality to make its existence little
more than fiction eventually the
possessive mask had to reconsider the
problem at hand even with infinite power
the unkillable still remained unkillable
rather than ask whether that meant its
own power was truly unlimited it instead
resolved to the only option it had left
with a snap of its host's fingers the
combined creature sent the hard-to-kill
reptile
away
far away universes upon multiverses of
distances were put between the masked
god and
scp-682 turning back towards the
destruction it had wrought on this world
scp-03 knew that the regenerating
reptile would be back but for now it had
more chaos to unfurl now go and check
out what if scp-096 wore scp-035
for another alternate anomalous outcome
of another scp wearing the infamous
possessive mask and if you haven't
already then why not watch the first
installment of what if scp-343 wore
scp-035
to catch up on the story so far